nein
vorsitzender
wir sind
mist
ja
v
ja meine damen meine herren lieber horst
herr ministerpräsident lieber
fraktionsvorsitzender lieber manfred
lieber generalsekretär lieber an die
liebe gerda meine sehr verehrten damen
meine herren das packte schon wenn man
ein bisschen auf die vergangenheit sieht
und dann gleichzeitig eine so
zukunftsweisende realistische
optimistische rede von wanfried lieber
die große bandbreite
deswegen sage ich das jahr 2015 ihr habt
das gerade gesehen ist natürlich für uns
schon ein besonderes jahr
es ist das hundertste geburtstag von
franz liszt haus und dieser geburtstag
der wird natürlich in diesem jahr noch
gebührend gefeiert werden
aber der erste der wichtigste und die
größte geburtstagsfeier die findet heute
in passau statt hier in passau hier war
franz-josef zu hause hier war seine
familie und hier ist auch heute
sozusagen die nachfolge csu familie
deswegen wir grüßen dich logischerweise
im himmel wir grüßen dich ganz herzlich
aus der stadt wo du immer so begeistert
uns die zukunft erklärt hast
er hat meine damen meine herren und er
hat ja immer gesagt wenn du nicht weisst
woher du kommst dann weiß auch nicht
wohin du willst alter spruch also wollen
wir auch mal wissen woher kommen wird er
hat den aschermittwoch geprägt wie kein
anderer
er hat aus dieser bayerischen
veranstaltung eine in deutschland und in
europa beachtete veranstaltung mit die
beachtete veranstaltung der csu im jahr
der aschermittwoch her gehört zur dna
der csu und strauß hat hier kräftig und
zeitlos gültige botschaften formuliert
hier hat er seine größten reden gehalten
ich war als generalsekretär an seiner
seite und ich durfte sozusagen als sein
nachfolger im amt
auch dann hier diese tradition
fortführen und natürlich wenn ein
solches ereignis ist und horst seehofer
sagte da kommst du und er greift noch
einmal das wort dann mache ich das gerne
denn hier hier hier das ist schon
angesprochen worden
trifft sich der verein für deutliche
aussprache
meine damen meine herren ein kritisches
wort das war einst ein sehr mächtiger
club inzwischen leidet er ein bisschen
an auszehrung klare kante wird heute in
unserer gesellschaft nicht mehr von
allen geschätzt
heute können wir doch wieder ein stück
ändern und deswegen ein herzliches grüß
gott an euch alle an die freunde der
klaren aussprache
gab diesen aschermittwoch immer als den
wichtigsten stammtisch bezeichnet gegen
alle klischees
heute gibt es ja die diskussion auf
sicht haben dies nur gibt und ob das
nicht die social media sozusagen
überflüssig gemacht haben nein das
glaube ich nicht
dem stammtisch meine damen meine herren
wird ja gerne etwas etwas dumpf
politisch eher etwas primitives
angelastet das haben wir meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren die haben das
nie so gesehen
für uns war das stammtisch und ist der
stand ist immer auch ein wesentliches
kommunikationsmittel zwischen bürgern
untereinander und bürgern und politikern
meine damen meine herren hier hat franz
strauß politik gemacht er hat das
aufgegriffen was die menschen bewegt und
sage ich noch einmal die asche mittwoch
das wird ja auch immer in den medien
30 40 jahre habe ich das verfolgen
können aber rasche mit wo steht nicht
für das geschliffene worte nicht für den
feinsinnigen ausdruck nicht hier findet
kein glatt gebügelter tor statt
hier hat strauß die sprache des volkes
gesprochen unverblümt direkt
verständlich offensiv und
leidenschaftlich mein name herren
was können wir was können wir heute muss
daraus lernen
zuerst müssen wir uns in der politik
immer wieder klarmachen
politik und demokratie sind für alle da
für alle nicht nur für elitäre kreise
nicht nur für die quappe die
gesellschaft und nicht nur für die
medien
es gibt ja leider immer mehr das ist ein
zug der zeit immer mehr die sich der
aktiven teilnahme an der demokratie bei
wahlen verweigern
am sonntag in hamburg die fortsetzung
knapp die hälfte geht nicht zur wahl
meine damen meine herren darüber wird
eigentlich ein bisschen zu wenig
diskutiert ein grund mich nicht der
alleinige ein grund ist dass uns viele
wähler nicht mehr verstehen
politik ist komplex die sprache der
politik ist komplex weil auch die lage
kompliziert ist und wir müssen es immer
wieder schaffen wie hier in nassau die
dinge herunterzubrechen für denjenigen
der sich nicht den ganzen tag mit
politik beschäftigt sondern das im
grunde genommen nur am rande wahr nimmt
auch den müssen wir motivieren und
gewinnen und bei uns behalten meinen
namen
ich weiß nicht ob das jedem gefällt aber
ich will mal einen satz von strauß
zitieren den als parteivorsitzender aber
auch als staats politiker gesagt hat ihr
erinnert euch rechts von der csu darf es
keine demokratisch legitimierte
politische kraft in deutschland geben
dieses wort dieses wort war und ist ein
eherner grundsatz der csu
auch wenn das in der großen union nicht
überall mehr so gesehen wird
dieses wort ist für mich ein vermächtnis
ein auftrag eine verpflichtung für jeden
einzelnen von uns
ich sage mal meine damen und herren es
ist eine riesenleistung eine
riesenleistung der csu in den letzten 60
jahren dass ich bis zum heutigen tage in
deutschland keine rechte partei
dauerhaft etablieren konnte
es gibt ja es gibt ja leute die meinen
sie müssten uns dafür auch noch
kritisieren
denen kann ich nur sagen und manfred hat
das kürze aus der europäischen
perspektive die ja nun auch in den
letzten sieben acht jahren intensiv
kennengelernt habe er hat auch schon
angesprochen meine damen und herren
wollen wir wie in frankreich die
verhältnisse in frankreich mit einer
immer stärkeren rechten mit front
national mit madame le pen wollen wir
eine situation wie in den vereinigten
wie im vereinigten königreich
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
mit nigel farage dem rechten und
rechtsausleger mit seiner judith partei
nein meine damen und herren anläufe gibt
es immer wieder denken wir nur an die
republikaner
wer hat die denn zurückgedrängt
die grünen waren es jedenfalls nicht mit
ihrem multi kulti und michi waschi meine
damen und herren
die spd war es auch nicht das war und
ist alleine das verdienst der csu und
deshalb meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren darf und wird die csu diese
integrationsaufgabe mitte rechts im
demokratischen spektrum niemals
vernachlässigen
meine damen meine herren ja wenn ich das
mal unterbrechen und ernst nehmen nicht
nur so dann sage mal in hamburg die wahl
ich will sie nicht sehr repräsentativ
nehmen aber sie hat gezeigt alle
parteien verlieren alleine solchen
emporkömmling an die afd
wir müssen meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren wir müssen meines erachtens
diese afd aufs korn nehmen
genau wie wir die republikaner aufs korn
genommen haben und wir müssen die
wir müssen meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren ihre ihre lösungsansätze sie
beschreiben nur die probleme die
probleme in der innere sicherheit die
probleme in der zuwanderung die probleme
in europa aber sie schaffen keine
lösungen und wir brauchen keine parteien
die nur an klagen ohne lösungsvorschläge
zu haben deswegen wollen wir die wähler
bei uns wieder haben
jetzt gibt es ja leider aber in
deutschland die meinen das historische
strauß wort würde nicht mehr gelten
die ortsparteien wurden ausschließlich
in die mitte des politischen spektrums
gehören die ränder könnten und müssten
nicht mehr so integriert werden
ich sage euch was für ein irrtum so
schwächt man die mitte und stärkt die
ränder damit würde man dem politisch die
politische stabilität deutschlands in
mit sicherheit in gefahr bringen
und nebenbei würde die union meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren denselben weg
auf bundesebene nach unten gehen wie in
die spd wegen der linkspartei schon
beschritten hat das würde in manchen
kommentator vielleicht gefallen aber das
kann nicht unser weg sein
meine damen und herren toleranz vielfalt
und was sind die themen in unseren
medien und in unserer politik
es ist ja grundsätzlich auch zu begrüßen
aber es gibt auch viele bürger und viele
bürgerinnen die das gefühl haben sie
kommen eigentlich mit ihrer
lebensperspektive gar nicht mehr so vor
das sagt mir eine ich gehört zu einer
minderheit
ich bin nicht punkt wo sie zeitlich mit
mir dann gesagt max kidd neue episode
zeit verheiratet sie stehen dafür
ausgehen
er ziehe meine kinder macht vielleicht
noch im verein im sportverein
ehrenamtliche aufgabe berät über mir
die politik sucht doch nach der mitte
ich sage euch meine sehr vielen damen
herren diese beiden beispiele das ist
die mitte und die müssen wir stärker
wieder berücksichtigen ansprechen
es finden sagen dass das die substanz
unseres volkes ist davon leben wir
100 jahre ist aus wie würde er mit
seiner politischen begabung mit seinen
politischen instinkt die lage 2015 den
beurteilen schwierig aber horst er würde
auf bayern schauen und ich glaube er
wäre sehr zufrieden
er ist gedanke ist gegangen
fast 88 da haben wir noch ganz klein
bisschen finanzausgleich bekommen
er wollte immer aus dem heraus
seine nachfolger haben das fortgesetzt
was er geschaffen
wenn ich mir anschaue die neueste
umfrage soll interessant vom bayerischen
rundfunk anfang des jahres viele viele
daten will nur eins raus ziehen die mir
weißt wie wundert haben 28 prozent der
bayerischen bevölkerung nach dieser
umfrage konnte auf die frage was ist
eigentlich das größte problem in bayern
keins mehr nennen lieber horst das ist
unglaublich aber glaubt du willst
durchaus dass es mehr werden die songs
in ordnung und insgesamt meine damen und
herren sind auch in deutschland die
daten gut er würde sich als langjähriger
finanzminister natürlich freuen dass zum
ersten mal seit 1969 in deutschland
keine neuen schulden mehr gemacht werden
45 jahre das ist meine damen und herren
das ist super
was haben wir darum gekämpft und lieber
horst vor zehn jahren bald haben wir
gegen alle widerstände den
ausgeglichenen haushalt durchgesetzt
du hast ihn fortgeführt und hast den
getoppt in dem du mit markus zusammen
zurückzahlt das ist schon eine sehr fern
damen und herren das ist das geheimnis
warum der aschermittwoch in passau
bedeutsamer ist als alle anderen
aschermittwochsveranstaltungen in bayern
oder in deutschland weil hier natürlich
auf leistung zu hause ist
trotzdem
auch wenn er meine damen und herren wird
ja heute nicht selbstzufrieden dahin
schauen
sein credo war immer wir müssen an der
spitze des fortschritts marschieren
ich sage das ist für uns vielleicht
eines der großen probleme das wohlfühlen
von heute das wohlfühlen von heute in
deutschland das meine damen und herren
sichert nicht den wohlstand von morgen
den satz müssen wir uns verinnerlicht
wir dürfen in unserer guten lage im
verhältnis zu anderen ländern nicht nur
versuchen die gegenwart zu verlängern
sondern müssen dynamisch und innovativ
sein
ich weiß meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren digitalisierung
es ist kein thema für den aschermittwoch
aber das ist ein thema für unser land
und für die wettbewerbsfähigkeit
die daten werden das erdöl des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts sein
horst seehofer liegt völlig richtig wenn
er jetzt den schwerpunkt auf die
digitalisierung liegt seines landes
bayerns und darüber hinaus natürlich wir
müssen uns fragen haben wir die produkte
und dienstleistungen für die
datenautobahn neueste meldung apple und
google bau neuer autos sind wir daran
haben wir ausgebildete fahrer für die
datenautobahn und so weiter das sind die
themen die uns sozusagen bewegen müssen
damit wir morgen so gut dastehen wie wir
heute im verhältnis zu den anderen
ländern das team und meine damen und
herren ein schwieriges thema ich möchte
sie ansprechen wird vielleicht nicht
jedem gefallen aber eine ganz große
sorge im moment in deutschland ist
natürlich die frage des geldes
die stabilität ist genug
es werde in der politik heißt diskutiert
was zu deutschland gehört und was nicht
zu deutschland gehört da komme ich noch
drauf
aber weil ich weiß was der
aschermittwoch der csu nicht nur in
bayern beobachtet wird sondern überall
sage ich ganz bewusst
ich weiß nicht ob du mir da zustimmen
kannst manfred an herrn trage an den
chef der europäischen zentralbank
ich sage das was horst seehofer was
markus söder mehrfach in den letzten
wochen gesagt haben
ein weicher euro gehört nicht zu
deutschland
früher heute das nochmal ein weiterer
gehöre nicht zu deutschland
wir haben gerade hier theo waigel und
ich immer geld versprochen
der euro wird mindestens so stabil sein
wie die thema das war dass das war das
vertrauen was wir eingefordert haben bei
den bürgern bürgern in deutschland in
den 90er jahren und ich sage auch genau
wie manfred leber zebras in griechenland
der bruch von verträgen und
vereinbarungen er gehört auch nicht zu
deutschland meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren
und
aggressive töne gegenüber den an
gegenüber andere helfen gehören nicht in
die europäische solidarität debatte auch
das klare ansage ich muss ja den hut
ziehen meine damen und herren von
wolfgang schäuble den ich nun jahrzehnte
kenne aber so hart und knorrig wir
gegenwärtig auftritt besser könnte es
auch der csu finanzminister nicht bahn
spitze
meine damen meine herren die europäische
zentralbank hat eine schwierige aufgabe
das erkenne ich absolut an und ich habe
immer ich habe mario draghi auch
verteidigt im jahre 2012 in einer
denkwürdigen sprache als er gesagt hat
die europäische zentralbank wird das
erforderliche tun um den euro zu halten
damals hat er mit dieser ansage den
spekulanten und den finanzmärkten den
krieg erklärt und er hat diese in die
knie gezwungen
die massiv auf den zerfall des euros
gesetzt haben
damals hat er den euro gerettet
so wie ich den damaligen schnitt und
schritt verteidige so besorgt bin ich
über die aktuelle situation wenn die
europäischen zentralbank jedes monat bis
herbst nächsten jahres
jedes jahr jedes monat 60 milliarden
plus sozusagen in den geldmarkt
einspeist er immer höher wird man sage
ihnen voraus meine damen und herren die
gefahr ist natürlich gegeben dass der
euro dann zur hardware die lehrer aber
das haben wir nicht versprochen
deswegen ich weiß meine damen meine
herren die europäische zentralbank ist
unabhängig naja muss man hinnehmen auch
wenn sie anders handelt als die politik
den menschen versprochen hat aber meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren diese
entscheidungen der europäischen
zentralbank sind keine gottes war teile
und ich sage meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren eine harte währung das ist
kein deutscher fetisch da gibt es gute
gründe
sparen ist eine deutsche tugend
es kann auf die dauer das sage ich ganz
offen es kann auf die dauer nicht
richtig sein dass der sparer der dumme
ist das wäre eine umkehrung der werte
65 jahre bundesrepublik deutschland und
wir müssen das auch politisch ausbrechen
ich kann mir ich kann mir nur wundern
wir alles in europa die geldschwemme und
die nullzinspolitik so toll findet die
folge dieser geldpolitik ist nämlich
unter anderen dass die schere zwischen
arm und reich auseinander geht
sparer und das ist die mehrzahl unseres
volkes die kleinen leute die 5 10 15 20
30.000 spaß haben und nichts mehr dafür
bekommen wer profitiert natürlich
logisch die aktien die aktionäre aber
ich muss natürlich sehen in deutschland
haben mit einer 8 prozent der
bevölkerung aktien
wir haben hier eigentlich aktien in
diesem saal meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren wenn die einen immer mehr
gewinnen und die anderen praktisch mit
ihrem schmalen geld hinten bleiben dann
verkehren wir die werte unseres
sozialstaates und das müssen wir in die
politische diskussion einführen vermisse
das ein bisschen
und ich sage noch mich erschreckt das
billige geld meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren kann nicht die lösung sein
wettbewerbsfähigkeit erzählst du nur mit
reformen aber nicht mit einer
geldschwemme und jetzt schauen sie mal
an was passiert denn mit unserem
betriebsrenten was passierte mit unseren
lebensversicherungen was passiert mit
den altersversorgungen der menschen die
sich privat aufbauen
sie werden immer sie werden immer
schwieriger die 30 dax unternehmen in
deutschland haben wegen der
nullzinspolitik 100 milliarden euro
zubuttern müssen gegenwärtig um die
betriebsrenten auf spur zu halten wenn
das so weitergeht bezahlen nicht nur die
jetzigen sparer sollen dann auch die
alten von morgen die fehlerhaftigkeit
dieser politik und deswegen sagen wir
das kann so auf dauer ohne politische
diskussion nicht mehr weitergehen
deswegen bitte ich auch hier
unterstützung
aber den vogel den vogel meine damen und
herren es schließt schon die neue
regierung ab die neue griechische
regierung
ich verstehe dass man aus dem teilstaat
heraus ein stück zeit braucht um das
regieren auch zu lernen durcheinander
meine damen und ein weniger
durcheinander in der sache und ein
bisschen mehr benehmen im ton wäre aber
schon angebracht und deswegen europa ist
ein kontinent des rechts
europa lebt vom prinzip dass verträge
eingehalten werden auch wenn sie von der
vorgängerregierung abgeschlossen sind
wenn dieses prinzip nicht mehr gilt dann
ist europa oder saks anders mit franz r
strauß pacta sunt servanda und denn
dieses prinzip des römischen rechtes
nicht mehr gilt dann ist europa am ende
nicht nur das latein und damit das muss
man immer wieder deutlich sagen
zu jeder gelegenheit und ich sage ganz
offen wie fasziniert die politisch die
linke in europa auf die neue regierung
in athen schaut
diese politik wird geradezu angehimmelt
weil sie von links kommt und zwar von
den selben leuten angehimmelt wie bei
uns die sogenannte practice wie ein grab
vor sich her tragen
eine koalition von linksextremen und
rechtsextremen in griechenland für die
linken hier kein problem jury zahl und
an den arterien meine damen und herren
sind sind jetzt ausländerfeind
nationalisten
und so garantie sie mit antisemiten in
der regierung mit an der regierung kein
problem da sage ich meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren das ist ein skandal
das gilt überall wo linksextremisten und
rechtsextremisten zusammen arbeiten
da muss die demokratie ein stoppschild
aufzeigen und da kann man nichts darüber
hinweggehen
und ich sage das auch weil die leute
aufregt der zebras er war faktisch und
ihre freunde in europa sollten sich
einmal überlegen wie viele dritte kann
man der kuh geben die man melken will
die deutschen sind sehr hilfsbereit
ungeduldig aber ich weiß nicht wie lange
meine sehr fern damen und herren angela
merkel wird in nazi-uniform und hitler
bart dargestellt
wolfgang schäuble genauso und
deutschland als das vierte reich von der
regierungspartei sozusagen bezeichnet
das ist eine geschichtsvergessenheit und
das müssen wir auch den griechen
entgegenhalten
angela merkel horst seehofer haben nicht
eine million beamte eingestellt in einem
land mit knapp elf millionen einwohnern
die griechische regierung tut gut tut ja
gerade so als hätten die deutschen 2010
blühende landschaften besetzt
dort hätten die deutschen dieses land
ruiniert das gegenteil ist richtig meine
damen und herren merkel und deutschland
und die anderen europäer
sie haben haften für 100 milliarden
schuldenschnitt und 278 milliarden
garantie es ist eine frechheit meine
damen und herren dass diejenigen die
interesse im interesse europas so viel
leisten und vor leisten so angemacht
werden das kann nicht sein und da muss
man auch deutlich für die deutschen
steuerzahler steuerzahler mal das wort
ergreifen
und du hast
lieber manfred mich hat es gestern fast
vom sitz gehoben
als mir berichtet worden ist aus der
finanzministerkonferenz in brüssel als
die finanzminister der slowakei die
finanzminister sloweniens die
finanzminister der baltischen staaten
dem griechischen finanzminister gesagt
haben dass ihr lebensstandard wesentlich
geringer sei als der in griechenland
worauf der finanzminister griechenlands
gesagt hat ihr mögt damit leben können
wir griechenland können das nicht so
arrogant kann man nicht an europa heran
gehen
deswegen darf ich darf ich einfach zum
gedächtnis ist heute nicht mehr
entscheidend aber doch interessant wer
war denn gegen die aufnahme
griechenlands in die eurozone
das waren im deutschen bundestag nur die
csu-abgeordneten das waren im
europäischen parlament nur die
csu-abgeordneten und das war im
bundesrat wird die csu die csu
staatsregierung nur soviel zur wahrheit
wir wollen darauf nicht mehr beharren
aber damals war die entscheidung richtig
und die entscheidung schröder und
fischer war falsch gibt es keine frage
letztes thema franz josef strauß hat
hier in passau meine damen und herren
versetzen ich zurück in die 60er 70er
jahre riesige ausführungen zum
atlantischen bündnis gemacht er hat
dafür gekämpft für das bündnis mit
amerika das war für ihn immer die
grundlage der freiheit
aber man wird er war auch ein
leidenschaftlicher europäer die damalige
auseinandersetzung zwischen atlantik und
kulissen strauß wollte einen stärkeren
europäischen pfeiler und es gebe viel zu
sagen im moment in zusammenhang mit der
ukraine und im zusammenhang mit minz
aber eines eines muss ich genauso
herausheben wie du andere dinge
herausgehoben hast zum ersten mal hat
die europäische union vertreten durch
deutschland und frankreich alleine am
tisch gesessen und hat über den frieden
in der ukraine mit russland als
europäische union über ein europäisches
problem sozusagen verhandelt und
zumindest eine tür geöffnet für mögliche
friedens entwicklungen weiter ich sage
ganz offen meine damen und herren das
ist ein unglaublich schwieriger prozess
aber das zeigt mir ganz deutlich wir
werden immer mehr künftig unsere
probleme in europa selber lösen müssen
und ich sage auch ganz offen mein wort
ich habe mich auf der
sicherheitskonferenz vor 14 tagen über
mekka ihn sehr geärgert und über die
amerikanischen senatoren
meine damen und mediale sich schnell
gesagt gebt doch den ein alibi
amerikaner gibt der ukrainischen armee
modernste defensivwaffen ich kann nur
sagen aus dem euro
welchen rückt aus dem europäischen
blickwinkel und hier stützt sich angela
merkel voll und ganz
ist das eine veränderung der situation
wenn die amerikaner mit
waffenlieferungen plötzlich in diesem
konflikt eine andere rolle spielen dann
weiß ich nicht was daraus wird und wir
sind die nachbarn und die amerikaner das
will ich auch deutlich sagen
deswegen müssen wir das selber machen
meine damen herren das bedrückende und
was wollen eine generation noch dauern
wird
das ist sozusagen der terrorismus der
mann betriebe angesprochen hat ich sage
mal meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren die wollen wir die terror
begegnen
es ist ja unglaublich was da an der
libyschen küste passiert 21 kopten
blutgetränkte mehr
ich meine das ist christen die wegen
ihres christsein sozusagen gekämpft
werden und uns und ich will das alles
gar nicht weiter beschreiben was sage
ich aber auch ganz klar meine damen und
herren
man kann nicht den islam
den kann man generell nicht und nicht
die 16 milliarden muslime auf der welt
unter generalverdacht stellen
das wird auch von allen wesentlichen
kräften unserer gesellschaft betont zu
recht aber wahr ist auch meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren die meisten
der mörder die meisten der männer die
maßnahmen morden berufen sich
ausdrücklich auf den koran
sie wollen ihre gräueltaten mit dem
choral rechtfertigen
ihre ziele sind kalifat und
gottesstaaten und deswegen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren der satz der
bei solchen anlässen von vielen immer
wieder gesagt wird
das hat mit dem islam nichts zu tun
dieser satz ist falsch das ist die
bittere wahrheit
die bittere wahrheit für die große
mehrheit der anständigen und
friedliebend muslime ihre religion wird
von verrückten als geisel genommen
da gibt es nur eine möglichkeit der
islam muss aus dieser geiselhaft befreit
werden und das könne nur in erster linie
die muslime selbst sie müssen aufstehen
in der ganzen welt gegen diese
mörderbanden um meine damen und herren
sie müssen aufstehen das erwarte ich vor
allen dingen auch von den arabischen
ländern ich prangere das an meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren da ich frage
das anders und zieht zum terroranschlag
in paris saudi arabien überhaupt keine
stellungnahme abgegeben habe aus einer
wachsweichen wir würden den islamisten
den größten gefallen tun denn wir aus
angst vor ihnen jetzt in europa
kulturkämpfe beginnen würden aber wir
dürfen ja wir wollen und ich weiß dass
das immer wieder kritisiert wird aber
soll so selbstgewiss schon über uns
selbst über unser land über uns
nachdenken
da gibt er seinen satz meine damen und
herren der heiß diskutiert wird
er lautet der islam gehört zu
deutschland
der islam meine damen und herren gehört
zu deutschland diesen satz mache ich mir
persönlich auf keinem falle zu eigen er
ist nämlich so falsch
das kann ich auch gar nicht weil ich
nicht weiß welcher islam gemeint ist ist
dies etwa der islam vor dem vor einer
woche ägyptens präsident als sie selbst
ein moslem gewarnt hat er sagt der koran
ist 1400 jahre alt überliefert des
islamischen denken wird für die ganze
übrige welt zur quelle von angst um
gefahr von mord und zerstörung oder
gehört der islam mit seinen zwangsehen
und mit seiner erniedrigung der frau
gehört der zu uns meines helfern damen
und herren da muss man sauber
differenzieren muslime gehören zu uns in
deutschland das ist keine frage
und für alle die zu deutschland gehören
gilt unsere deutsche leitkultur und was
ist die deutsche leitkultur was ist die
deutschen leitkultur die deutsche
leitkultur sind die ersten 20 artikel
des deutschen grundgesetzes deutschland
ist den rechtsstaat steht im deutschen
grundgesetz das ist deutsche leitkultur
hier gilt nur das gesetz in deutschland
und nicht die scharia deutschland
deutschland ist eine demokratie hier
gibt es kein kalifat wer das gericht
muss briten will muss raus deutschland
gelten meinungsfreiheit und
pressefreiheit
hier gibt es keine peitschenhiebe für
blogger und in deutschland gilt die
religionsfreiheit andere religionen
werden nicht als minderwertig betrachtet
und in deutschland gilt die
gleichberechtigung die
gleichberechtigung von mann und frau
keine chance sie keine chance bürger
keine behandlung von frauen als menschen
zweiter klasse
das meine damen und herren ist deutschen
leitkultur wir hier leben muss muss das
100 prozent akzeptieren oder er kann
hier nicht leben
und lassen sie mich ein allerletztes
nachdenkliches wort sagen ein
allerletztes nachdenklich ort hier in
passer möchte ich das hinzufügen
ich tue das ganz bewusst auch in
erinnerung meines lehrmeisters zehn
jahren eben staus büro zu sitzen das war
die beste lehre für die weitere
politische tätigkeit das sage ich euch
ich tue das ganz bewusst in erinnerung
an strauss zu deutschland meine damen
und herren zur deutschen auch zur
deutschen bahn gehört das
menschheitsverbrechen des holocaust es
gehört zu deutschland jeder der in
deutschland leben will gleich welcher
region gleich woher kommt ob aus
islamischen buddhistischen oder
sonstigen ländern
jeder der hier in deutschland leben will
der muss diese historisch gewachsene
verantwortung der deutschen für die
jüdischen mitbürger und für israel
akzeptieren das gehört zu deutschland
und wer das nicht tut der hat in
deutschland keine berechtigung zu leben
und sich als deutscher zu bezeichnen
das halte ich für angst weil ich mich
100 jahre der große meister ein blick
zurück zeigt wir können uns als csu nur
selber schlagen deshalb ich weiß das ist
doch schwierig aber er hat immer von der
legendären geschlossenheit bartl du
kannst die berliner wird der lehre
legendären geschlossenheit geredet die
uns sowohl zu unterschieden hat von der
genscher partei und der kulturteil als
ehrenvorsitzender der sich bewusst ist
diese ehre hier von euch übertragen
bekommen zu haben
der versucht seine botschaft als
ehemaliger als wie sagt man so schön
älter setzen rüberzubringen ist meine
botschaft an alle kolleginnen und
kollegen die gegenwärtig hier im
kabinett in berlin in münchen ist für
uns für die partei für das land
verantwortung tragen
die tun das ja nicht in erster linie für
sich selber das wird oft
fälschlicherweise der politik
unterstellt das stimmt ja nicht
sie tun es für unsere gemeinsame sache
sie tun es für bayern und für
deutschland
deshalb sind alle in der pflicht
zusammenzustehen und unsere legendäre
geschlossenheit so sicher zu gestalten
zu machen wenn wir zusammenhalten wenn
wir zusammenhalten lieber horst dann ist
die csu weiterhin unschlagbar dafür
wollen wir arbeiten hier an erster
stelle
ich helfe ihnen und wieder mal aus in
dem sinne alles erdenklich gute für dich
alles erdenklich gute für die csu alles
erdenklich gute für bayern und für
deutschland und hoffen wir meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren dass es
gelingt aus minsk noch eine friedens
entwicklung zu machen und der dank geht
auch hier an angela merkel gar keine
frage
der respekt vor ihrem
einsatz in dieser hoch komplizierten
schwierigen geschichte physisch wie
psychisch der respekt ist riesengroß wir
stehen an deiner seite und die tipps
sind alles erdenklich gute für euch und
für den aschermittwoch dankeschön
meine damen und herren tochter edmund
stoiber